I didn't have it you dumbass yeah
hydrations garbage i really suggest all
one of you idiots done install a nice
try guys happy face
that's like garbage I suck I hate you
Sinatra was once known as one of the
most toxic players and overwatch people
didn't talk about his incredible
mechanical skill or his deep hero fool
they only talked about how much it'd
suck to play with him and who could
blame them he did more damage to his
teammates and his opponents I was like
just a dumb kid like then like when I
was 16 I was bad but these days people
have different things to say about
Sinatra he's Enys here oh we're here
2019 overwatch the MVP Sinatra he's a
role model working on myself developing
like my personality and just becoming a
better person in general he's the best
overwatch player so how did Sinatra go
from the most toxic person an overwatch
to the best player in the game in the
span of just one year I've grown a lot
last season I was you know a pretty
pretty toxic you know ego selfish kid
well as a 16 year old aspiring probes
natural love to [ __ ] talk other players
to the point where it became the first
thing you thought of when you heard his
name
nice try guys happy face where was all
this aggression coming from maybe it was
from his early attempts playing baseball
I was like JV in high school like
freshman sophomore so I knew I wasn't
going anywhere but like no I knew it was
long maybe he felt pressure to perform
to become the best or maybe he was just
a teenager being a teenager
whatever the reason Sinatra's toxicity
wasn't doing his reputation in the
overwatch community many favorites and I
really can't take this tells me the most
especially when the worst player and
overwatch Lee tries to [ __ ] me
pretend like he's good at the game or
something
and then just start stirring the game
cuz he doesn't get what he wants anytime
his name wasn't mentioned online people
immediately started talking about how he
had a bad attitude
how he harassed other players and how
well he was just a dick yeah I know I
don't know why you're throwing like
you're saying it yourself I don't know
why dude responsive Demi you literally
know I forgot to start playing csgo but
the release of overwatch in 2016 was
life-changing for it was the game that
finally gave him the opportunity to go
pro and sure his parents were worried
but they came around um for I waited til
Christmas time actually because I want
to make it easier yeah I wanted them to
be more willing you know Sinatra quickly
signed with selfless and though the team
didn't pick up any huge of victories his
mechanical skills did put him on a lot
of other teams radars
I'm gonna point out one day run on the
point he's in open-face his name's babe
I'm on him I might just carry it
disgusting I don't hear it
Sinatra showed off more of the
mechanical skills that made him famous
while playing for Team USA at the 2017
overwatch World Cup but he was quickly
smacked down by team South Korea Oh off
that Sinatra felt personally responsible
for I expected to do really well against
Korea but honestly I've never played a
Korean before that so I didn't know how
they played and then I just played way
too aggressive and I did it I didn't
that yes I just did really poorly so
yeah I'm pretty sure we lost cuz I
didn't do well despite that there were
two teams fighting over Sinatra heading
into the first season of the overwatch
League the London Spitfire and the San
Francisco shock Sinatra ended up
choosing the shock but there was just
one problem he was too young to play at
just 17 years old yo sup guys - not sure
just want to say that I'm super stoked
to be representing San Francisco the
over our league or stacked we're nutty
let's go and then after he signed his
salary leaked 150 thousand dollars a
year that was triple the league's a
minimum salary and though some people
started calling him mr. 150k other
people started calling him overpaid
honestly it kind of sucks cuz I'm like
the only player that will rush leave as
a league salary and everyone thinks that
I have the biggest salary over watch
League which I don't so like before I
came into the overwatch leave everyone
had an unreal expectation of me like oh
he's gonna come in and just one v6
everybody and carry the team and go like
20 you know so I think I just put me at
alike a disadvantage it got me really
nervous like I felt like I had to
perform Sinatra sat on the sidelines
unable to prove that he wasn't overpaid
unable to prove that he wasn't the toxic
little [ __ ] everyone thought he was and
after four long months
Sinatra finally made his debut he just
turned 18 on Saturday he's finally old
enough to play in the overwatch League
Darius the man in south now the first
time we get to see him almost halfway
through the entire
Sinatra's first season didn't go too
well for doc top the agent look like
asking me bought that super going down
now shock we're so close
but they are in big trouble now some
people still thought he was overpaid
some people still thought he was toxic
but whatever the reason was the haters
still went to town I like read a lot of
like Reddit and Twitter and all that
like the articles about me and everyone
would just like flame me so I'm not like
broke my mental actually last season
despite being a superstar in soloqueue
hundred just couldn't pull off a win for
his team eventually Sinatra realized
that his individual skill wasn't enough
but all that big talk and toxicity
wasn't leading to victory season one for
me honestly was like it was like a
building block for season two because I
wanted to learn a lot about overwash
League and what's about and like gain
confidence and not only be like nervous
on stage so going into season two
Sinatra tried to turn everything around
unknown for being toxic just not a good
person
but a good player so I think it's just
working on myself developing like my
personality and just becoming a better
person in general moving into a house
with the rest of his teammates for
Sinatra to get closer with them making
their communication better in game and
his new coach Krusty taught him how to
play smarter and better as a cohesive
unit this season I got to give it to my
coaching staff a crusty junk buck 9k
they really helped me just grow as a
player an individual a teammate and a
leader and the changes work well here
comes the not for us delete you out of
your Mac and just
another graviton ready to go 53 seconds
between absolutely messed up the play
set up by Smurfs the shock finished
stage 2 of over washing season 2 without
dropping a single map and then Sinatra
led them to victory in the state finals
the grab from Sinatra comes in and the
shuk have done it
they are your stage two champions great
when that happened I just jumped up and
started yelling with my team and I was
sure to cry the first like five seconds
I don't know how or why Sinatra was
delivering big time he wasn't just
performing mechanically he was also
speaking up on calm becoming the team's
de-facto in-game leader remember we
could engage disengage in the head
equipment with that bubble I've become
more of a leader yes since the season
one I'm always calming now which is like
crazy to me because I'd never thought I
would play our game it bubble these kids
yeah right or left right
nice Sinatra could do it all
he wasn't just an amazing Zarya he was
also playing tons of dps heroes and was
dishing out some of the highest hero
damage in the leaf simply put he was one
of the best players in the game so not
just tearing it up right now the guy is
a phenomenal freak of nature he goes
with the dragon plays already got it so
far but Sinatra's true test came in the
season to overwatch League grand finals
where he had to face off against the
Vancouver Titans the Titans were the
only team that could consistently push
the shock to their own limits and their
clash was going to be legendary I'll
complain some aggressively but tonight
already has so not to go see their
little kiss that disruption in the
backline video strike he can trip the
circuit
the last hunt for the title steps up he
is filmed dizzy now dental appointments
Lyme is already ready for the fight the
wrecking ball is down
[Applause]
the shocked one but all eyes are on
Sinatra he's incredible performance all
year long reached its peak in stage four
and the finals and in the end he lifted
the coveted MVP trophy this has been one
of my biggest goals coming into this
season
ever since I seen Jonah Quinn it's been
my biggest goal so I'm just really happy
and grateful arena but Sinatra wasn't
ready to stop at just one MVP title he
was determined to prove to whatever
haters that were left that he was the
best player in the world and the place
to do it was 2019 overwatch World Cup
the same tournament where he
disappointed himself just two years
before I think we have it now is just a
player experience maybe like being on
stage and like overwatch league stage
helped us a lot with like nerves and
stuff so I don't know what happened
those first years maybe like nerves got
to us or something because like we
didn't do well on stage at all and we
knew we're a good team first Sinatra got
his revenge by beating team south
Colinas just like his next target buddy
runs into a fortified orissa first it
doesn't matter speed body [ __ ] pace
budget he's right because we whatever it
takes so that just got what you need
help Carly's getting close
going going
the USA
[Applause]
the next Tuesday and the USA
thank done it through swayback supple
honey Schubert's without - knocks them
away from where that means the dead for
the era stuff
another graffiti flux that was quick -
I've seen the glory medial strike
perfect g1 evil tau plus G's way a place
of kills for the young superstar
[Applause]
three years of heartbreak
[Applause]
the end of the day Team USA stood
victorious and Sinatra of course was
instrumental in that mixture earning
himself yet another MVP trophy it means
the world to me obviously but definitely
gotta give it up to my team if it
weren't for them I'd literally be
nothing cool I think Cory should a guy
MVP personally made shot - Cory popped
off um but yeah just happy I thought it
was his pregame rituals before we go to
the arena I always like to have slippers
on and like while we're at the arena
practicing that I still have my slippers
on but when we're getting ready for the
match that's when I put my sneakers on
and it's the same figures he's
commitment to being a better person and
a better player don't kill him with
kindness kill him with success or
torture them with success so I don't
know I always thought about that quote
and like just kept my head down and
grinded hard till I just be the best I
can be or the love and support of his
teammates friends and family the second
I got like an ounce for like shock and
like Team USA I don't know they're he's
all really hyper me typing and all that
stuff and I talk to them a lot too and
they're really really happy for me and
when I go back home like they're oh he's
really excited for me as well in one
short year
Sinatra overcame his personal demons and
became the best player in the world are
you the best player in the world
yeah yes
just wait for the knock Matt wait for
the knock I am the one who knocks
[Music]
I'm Denmark playground that's gonna be
an N board so thank you thank you